schachcomputer sprachassistenten
selbstfahrende autos und immer
menschlicher werdende roboter
[Musik]
künstliche intelligenz ist auf dem
vormarsch und nicht mehr wegzudenken
dabei denken viele von uns balkan oder
auf englisch an killermaschinen wie wir
sie aus den filmen kennen aber auch im
echten leben waren experten wie bill
gates oder allen masc immer wieder
eindringlich vor den gefahren durch
künstliche intelligenz und bestimmt habt
ihr auch schon verstörende videos wie
dieses hier gesehen
gleichzeitig hat sich die
bundesregierung zum ziel gesetzt
deutschland zum weltweit führenden
standpunkt für künstliche intelligenz zu
machen und während manche experten davor
warnen dass unzählige arbeitsplätze
durch ki verloren gehen können liegt
auch eine chance darin für die
menschheit nie wieder arbeiten zu müssen
dass sich selbst weiter entwickeln und
dadurch vielleicht irgendwann aus den
fugen geraten könnten das wisst ja
wahrscheinlich aber wie zugänglich ist
das ganze kann bald jeder einfach so
schöpfer von künstlichen leben werden
genau das will ich diese woche
herausfinden
also zuerst muss ich mir natürlich
überlegen was meine ki überhaupt können
soll k s sind nämlich ziemlich einfach
idioten das heißt sie konnten eine sache
extrem wohl und sonst nix also ganz so
krass wie in den film wo sich eine ki
immer schneller und schneller alles
selber beibringen ist es nicht noch
nicht vielleicht könnte er dieses video
in dem eine klette bird lernt und
komplett zerstört oder das gleiche mit
dem google chrome dino das heftigste
wäre natürlich wenn ich eine karriere
anzurichten würde die sich komplett
selbst beibringt wie man übermenschlich
fehlerfrei meine app davos gespielt und
auch niemals runter fällt gerade jetzt
wo in ein zwei wochen gerade aus gelb 18
rauskommst also als multiplayer update
mit der cross plattform steam version
wer ist eigentlich schon geil wenn mir
meine ki den highschool man im eigenen
spiel für immer sichern würde wenn ihr
wissen wollt ob ihr besser sein als die
die jetzt an züchter könnt ihr euch das
game natürlich gern im app store oder
playstation runterladen aber zurück zum
thema halo ist dumme frage aber wie
macht man das kommt darauf an was zu
machen möchte ist mir immer eigentlich
ja also nein es wäre natürlich wenn sie
sich meine planungs geld selber
beibringen würde dann würde ich dir
neuronales netz empfehlen was mit green
force mit learning arbeit ist er perfekt
ich sie alles im monat kannst du dir
schon geben da du hast du eine woche
oder ja das ist sportlich enforcement
learning an sich ist schon machine
learning technologie die nicht ganz ohne
ist und dass dann noch mit einem
neuronalen netz für bilderkennung zu
kombinierten macht eigentlich zwei nicht
einfache sachen und du hast noch nie da
vorprogrammiert also das ist schon
ziemlich hart
wo fange ich als im westen an damit sie
möglichst flott geht und damit zurück zu
flirts davon gibt es nämlich ein
öffentlich zugängliches projekt bei dem
etwas
ich es versucht wurde wenn du dir flap
herauskopiert ist und wirklich nicht von
null anfangen muss dann ist es möglich
aber ich sage es sehr sportlich
ich bin gespannt wie weit schafft
morpheus hat heute übrigens ein video
hochgeladen in dem er erklärt wie man
den stil von bildern mit neuronalen
netzwerken auf andere überträgt das habe
ich euch auch verlinkt ich glaube ich
habe inzwischen endlich eine halbwegs
gute vorstellung weniger funktioniert
und wie sie sachen lernt damit mein
kleiner kino lehren was er machen soll
braucht auf einem zwei informationen zum
ersten was kann er überhaupt machen in
unserem fall ist das folgendes nach
links gehen nach rechts gehen nicht
gehen springen und nicht springen also
fünf seiten dieser fünf sachen passieren
dann erst mal komplett zufällig aber
damit in unserem neuronalen netzwerk die
strukturen bilden können die dafür
sorgen dass wir unser gewünschtes
ergebnis haben muss unsere kann
natürlich wissen was du machen soll und
das kann man sich ungefähr so vorstellen
wie wenn man ein haustier trainiert
nikon sein kann man gibt dem anfang der
belohnung wenn etwas richtig gemacht hat
und im fall der ki sogar eine bestrafung
wenn sie etwas falsch gemacht hat unter
der haube besteht das natürlich aus mega
komplizierten geburt meiner mama das ist
im grunde genommen das für ihn vors
meint learning von dem orpheus geredet
hat das ganze ist aber leichter gesagt
als getan
zwar weiß ich jetzt wie eine ki
theoretisch funktionieren soll und habe
die flat bird ki di mi amor falls
empfohlen hat als grundlage aber das
ganze zu programmieren und auf dem skate
anzuwenden ist doch ganz schön schwierig
für mich ich weiß nicht wo ich anfangen
soll und tutorials auf diesem gebiet
sind eher wissenschaftliche arbeiten
wohl davon ausgegangen wird dass man die
hälfte schon weiß und so verbringe ich
fast den ganzen tag auf der suche und
stolpere dabei tatsächlich auf allen us
firma open mit ihrem projekt universe
sie sich vorgenommen haben eine ki zu
entwickeln die alle computerspiele lösen
kann um meinem kleinen kino lieben
eintauchen reicht es heute aber nicht
ich habe die richtige fährte und folge
verschiedenen tutorials schritt 1
installieren
ok schritt 2 in meinem dino augen
verleihen in form von lakers mit denen
er die umgebung abtasten kann und
schritt 3 erstellen welche aktion mein
dino ausführen soll also um links gehen
rechts gehen gar nicht gehen so wie
springen oder eben nicht springen das
mag jetzt total simpel klingen ist es
aber in der praxis leider nicht weswegen
nicht verzweifelt dem ersteller der
youtube tutorial reihe die ich gerade
verfolge eine e mail schreiben und er
antwortet sogar und einen tag später auf
jeden fall immer ein bisschen gespannt
weil ich habe mir das spiel
heruntergeladen auch ein bisschen
angeschaut es ist schon schwer
sebastian hilft mir dabei den ganzen
kopf den ich aus verschiedenen tutorials
zusammengesucht habe auf das gelb
anzuwenden cool dankeschön
da sind wir das problem jetzt erstmal
gelöst ich arbeite noch bis spät in die
nacht und versuche alles für den ersten
trainingslauf zum laufen zu bringen
so aber bevor die karriere gestartet
wird muss ich erstmal die ganzen level
ein bisschen leichter machen damit sie
es halt nicht von anfang an schon so
schwer hat ja so leicht auch wenn ich
dafür baue ich das geld noch einmal
komplett um ich entferne die kometen
alle level bausteinen die lava enthalten
und auch die beweglichen plattformen und
sahen ein paar stunden später ist es
endlich soweit sie liebt ja blöd oder
was machst du da ist die falsche
richtung ich wunder mich wieso immer
nach links springt ich hab's gefühl dass
der versucht nur dieses wenige punkte zu
kriegen weil er springt immer runter und
läuft immer nach links 6 jetzt hofft er
nach rechts ich hab ein bisschen was
geändert ja und schon sollte jetzt
eigentlich merken dass er wenn da ein
paar sachen mal anders macht vielleicht
mehr oder weniger report kriegt und
dadurch hoffentlich ein bisschen was
lernen
ich bin stolz für gespannfahrer zum
erstmal auf das erste plattform
herauskommt hat das springen jetzt
einfach nur auf und ab und denkt er wird
dabei besser ach so der weder dafür
belohnt wie lange er nach rechts geht
und nicht wie weit das mal ändern
erstaunlich mit welchen kleinen fehlern
ich meine ki in eine völlig falsche
richtung lenken kann wie auch im echten
leben muss man die recht vorsichtig sein
welches verhalten man sich angewöhnt und
belohnt bleibt nur zu hoffen dass die
menschen die irgendwann wirklich mal ein
extrem mächtigen ks arbeiten sich nicht
so einfach austricksen lassen
wir starten mit dem test 7 gemacht haben
jetzt nicht testen jetzt mal bitte
vielleicht springt ja sogar das ding auf
die plattform
[Musik]
oh mein gott holy moly der ist ja übel
wald mega dusel aber ja wird schon
daraus lernen glauben ich kann meine ki
lernt laufen ja oh mein gott es ist echt
geil
es ist so clever das ding ist das in
zehn minuten aber gelernt hat
mal schauen was das ding kann wenn ich
die ganze nacht durchlaufen das
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
erst einmal eingefroren und zwar um 4
uhr 13 also hat glaube ich nur eine
dreiviertelstunde durchgemacht mal
schauen wie die kariert und einer
komplett unbekannten welt zurecht kommt
strahlkraft ist schon geil dass er
rasiert hat schon ab er rasiert er war
übel
ich hatte nicht was ich mache hier
nichts
er hat einfach komplett raus das game
137 meter gerade geschafft ist er besser
als 80 prozent der community
tatsächlich ist die nummer 34 damit
besser als 30 prozent aller davis cup
spieler aber da ist noch viel luft nach
oben
auch spannend wie der testlauf hier
verlaufen als bisher am anfang immer
besser und immer was aber irgendwann hat
es wirklich ein plateau erreicht ist
schlechter geworden
bisher wurden diese emirates hier
allerdings noch komplett ignoriert ich
gebe der ki also ab sofort eine
belohnung jedes mal wenn sie einen
emerald einsammelt wird sie sich dann
zum ersten mal nach links drehen um
versteckt der ems zu holen
wir geben unseren player einmal das neu
entwickelte gehirn
ich habe mich gebaut das ist die
lemminge
na gut das was dein schuchmann hat man
gerade noch den tipp gegeben dass sich
einstellen kann wie oft ich diese
anwendung öffnen möchte und dadurch halt
diese einzelnen testläufe zehnmal oder
20 mal so schnell sein können dass nach
einer stunde das gehirn
ok also funktioniert so okay er springt
überlagert das ist so eine schwere
stelle das schaffen so viele spieler
nicht obenan gott die ist richtig holy
moly das ist so das ist so cool
mannschaft mittlerweile auch diese
nehmen die schaffte immer noch nicht
dass es ist zeit für den finalen test
alles ist eingestellt es ist gerade acht
uhr morgens alle fehler sind behoben das
training wird gestartet und ich geh
schlafen
achteinhalb stunden später sind wir
jetzt hier zum vergleich die lernkurve
von unserem vorherigen champion der nur
ein bio meistern musste ging jetzt
diesmal deutlich schwerfälliger weil die
level viel schwieriger wurden weswegen
jetzt auch acht mal so lange gedauert
hat unseren aktuellen champion über den
belohnungs wert unseres vorherigen
champions zu bringen diese grafen zeigen
jeweils das lernverhalten von einer
anderen neuen ki aber um die entwicklung
mal wirklich am spiel zu sehen lassen
wir hier die gleiche ki also unsere
nummer 62 gegen sich selbst antreten
einmal oben der stand an dem sie nach
sieben minuten training war in der mitte
der stand nach einer stunde und unten
nach ganzen drei stunden und im
anschluss die finale ki nach acht
stunden erstaunlich ist dass die carina
hat sieben minuten training bereits so
weit kommt aber sie sieht schon etwas
ungeschickt aus und bei 105 meter
springt sie anderen die lava was ihr
nach einer stunde hier schon nicht mehr
passiert und die bewegungen sind auch
deutlich flüssiger wodurch sie auch viel
schneller durch das gelände navigiert
und sogar das mooseum erreicht aber
trotzdem ist nach 189 metern schluss
auch wenn sie nach drei stunden immer
noch leichte probleme hat und einfach
auf der stelle springt ist die ki nach
drei stunden bereits deutlich schlauer
und benutzt hier sogar kleine bugs aber
ob sie erreicht die nächste landschaft
die wüste nicht wie wird sich hier die
acht stunden version schlagen wie gut
ist die beste die ich an trainiert habe
wirklich nach acht stunden und 20
minuten waren die bewegungen von ki 62
extrem flüssig diese stelle hier
meistert sie ohne auch nur eine sekunde
zu zögern
er spielt sieht aus wie das von einem
sehr guten spieler es sieht aus als
könnte sie ewig weiteren nichts kann sie
aufhalten
oha jetzt übertreibt der mann komplett
jetzt müsste es kein glück zu schaffen
außer der komet und auch beim zweiten
versuch die nici mit bravour meistert
scheitert es bei 320 metern am comet
[Musik]
versuch nummer 3 100 200 300 meter und
ich würde nicht nein so weit war noch
nie wüste okay nein es sei ja jetzt bin
ich gespannt wie er in den
der grund dafür war ein fehler von mir
die kakteen waren nämlich unsichtbar für
die ki innerhalb meiner experiment woche
habe ich es also leider nicht geschafft
ok zu entwickeln die alles rasiert ich
habe den fehler aber gerade schon
behoben und noch vieles optimiert und
jetzt gerade wird trainiert die bereits
nach einer stunde doppelt so hohe werte
erreicht hat wie unsere acht stunden
version ich werde trotzdem noch ein paar
stunden laufen lassen und sie dann
später im stream euch zeigen
das training ist schon gestartet wenn
ihr das video seht also klickt gern mal
auf den linken wie die beschreibung und
schaut vorbei oder schaut euch die
zusammenfassung auf ein zweiter kanal an
wenn ihr den sieg verpasst habt das
tagesgeld 1.8 updates mit multiplayer
cross plattform steam version neuen
items und neuen kinos steht vor der tür
auf meinem zweiten halbzeit jede woche
zwei bis drei update videos sudan und
schaut euch gerne das mal an und den
damen skeptisch findet ihr natürlich
auch alle informationen die wir
natürlich jetzt hier niemanden
gefährlich aber ihr seht es vielleicht
an diesen exponential kurven wie phlox
hat einen gewissen punkt gegen kann ich
erwarte dass zum beispiel dass ich heute
noch eine perfekte hinbekommen und
ähnlich wird es bei k s mit anwendungen
in echten leben auch sein und ihres
internet zugänglich das ganze ist also
ich weiß auch nicht was ich euch auf den
weg mitgeben soll außerdem habe man
schnell bei den zehnjährigen mit dem
youtube tutorial um die welt dazu zu
verkaufen um süßigkeiten zu bringen also
wenn er jetzt mal schauen wollt wir
besser sei als kelly dann ladet euch
gerne die app in der beschreibung runter
wenn ihr mich jetzt auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte
dann abonniere gerne gaal und dann sehen
wir zunächst mal wieder was gut
[Musik]